what would you say to those people that
maybe believe he's a one-hit wonder
I don't even tell them how long did it
take you to crawl out of that sad moment
I go to my room I was like almost crying
every day here at the police report
offices in New York City we were going
to go across the pond into from Osama
but we really just got to go like across
the street to his hotel cuz he is in New
York City Mo is obviously one of the
most recognizable faces around the globe
and he's one of the biggest soccer stars
ever but he's making news right now for
more than just this no it's the very
first thing I think that when I look at
you as I see this hair and it's
fantastic
how would you describe your hair sexy
you know what the hair really has a mind
of its own there's a Twitter account
dedicated to your hair did you know that
most al lawz hair and it's just about
your hair and how it look that day the
people in England they miss that kind of
hair very careful on Dino and dong hair
but the kids in they were forced I love
my head so much well that's one thing in
soccer I feel like hair is a big thing
and a lot of players their hair is a
part of their kind of soccer i
didn't--it e do you feel like that with
your hair
with my head yeah I just feel like this
is my style this is my how it looks like
so I don't want to change it a lot but
we're probably next time we're gonna do
a new haircut I'm not sure okay now I
actually have a video for you that was
sent to me that somebody wants to say hi
why do you think it is this is spent
every moment in my seat
now listen then you know the man is a
pure scorer all know what the numbers
are praising the game even though he's
not talking to you so it's so good so
calm I need him before I like him a lot
to me it's great player and a great
person in a makeup football I'm not a
great great fan but I like it now
because it's still college football so
he has target big target in his mind and
he has passion about it and he wants
like rich history who has better hair
you are Odell Beckham jr. it's very easy
to decide me let's see you're thinking
about going blonde okay is it sometimes
nice to come to a place like New York
where if you go outside overseas I'm
sure you'll get mobbed everybody wants
to talk to you but here you're able to
blend in does that feel nice or do you
feel like you blend down here that's
what I expect before I came but after I
came
there's like a little bit difficult when
I came here and see the people also
react the same way as Europe so do you
ever feel overwhelmed being Mozilla as a
human being you wanna just feel free
listen when I say it's a lot if the
people will take it in I'm complaining
I'm not complaining but it's just some
time you feel like you want freedom to
work to do whatever he wants
so you come to New York and you did not
be yes we are breaking the law
jaywalking too cool to see that even if
someone sees you
that's like a big moment for them that's
honestly what that's what I take each
moment like that when I get like okay
come on guys it's too much I just feel
like okay you make his life better or he
just feel happy
yeah so that's something also makes me
feel good yeah yeah I think I'm happy
about that
yeah and it's a fun place to see like
it's fun it's fun I wish I could come
again in the summer so okay so I know
you tried some New York Pizza yes New
York is known for food but it's not it's
gotta be as good as the Egyptian here
because I can hear my name so we do
something new but how great is that like
cuz I feel like in Egypt you're probably
the most famous person that has okay you
know what I know the few songs yeah the
Egyptian king right yeah so expectations
for you are pretty high in the football
world like last year you have 40-plus
goals so now it's like anything less
than that is beautiful um right it's
like the expectation for the people the
people is very very high so so basically
you score 40 sunset last season now they
want you to score 60 next year I wanted
you to score 90 and this doesn't work
like that what would you say to those
people that maybe believe last year was
just a good year he's a one-hit wonder
what would that message be I don't need
to even to answer the man answered him
in the field so I'm still the top
scholar on my team is very close to win
two title of the season so
what are your memories of the injury
that you suffered and the Champions
League level
it's tough time it was very bad you know
final Champions League big dream for
yourself and for the city for the fans
for everyone want to win the Champions
League you won't win it all so to write
the history it was also before the World
Cup 1 months before the World Club and
when I fell down when I go up to my
stand on the ground and I felt something
it was like my my mind was painful more
than the body was I just fell Wow the
Champions League is over for me and the
World Cups over I just felt like I don't
deserve that
I felt something my shoulder immediately
I went to dressing room was just crying
it was it was very tough for me at that
moment how long did it take you to crawl
out of that sad moment I think it's it's
just still here until now I mean because
you didn't win it so you feel like you
were close to to win the Champions
League final Champions League and you
didn't win it I go to my room it was
like almost crying every day yeah I can
tell even when you talk about it now
that that was definitely a very like a
defining moment for you yeah actually
honestly it's tough it's tough when I
think about it because it's like
something kill your dream like it's the
Champions League final the World Cup but
in that in one moment like disappeared
is it's also difficult they serve it
when you were growing up I know you were
going back and forth from fields to get
better tell me about some of those those
Mama's for you you know straight now I
just feel like wow that's like that was
me like when I was very young I used to
play in the tree not thinking about how
he come in the future how big you would
be like it's it's a lot of things to
change but it's like also getting
emotional when you feel like wow this
could be one day in huge player or very
famous so that's something it's really
very nice and also when I sit like a
young player or the kids planes to it
I'm just sitting in this when they gonna
be famous when they wanna be you have
money you will have everything and you
will be happy so just enjoy the life now
[Music]
so what are you motivated by in life I
just want to do everything I could do or
even just in my mind lights there's many
thing and I feel like it's so difficult
to keep it so I put it as a target then
I try to reach it
what are some of those targets I think I
ditch one of them yesterday so I think
it's a difficulty on an Egyptian and one
of the hundred and twenty people in the
world so that's something very very huge
and something also motivate intubate me
to to do better and to improve myself in
in the field and of of the field what is
the number one issue in the world right
now that you're fighting for I think you
got a woman right that's the most
important thing I think something we
need to change them in the Middle East
war and
saying we're creating a woman by the way
what I'm saying is we have flexibility
to do that much better it's something in
our hand in our minds there was a video
that went around of you playing
basketball so I'm gonna show you that
video and I want you to walk me through
this basketball workout okay let's see
[Music]
then it wasn't terrible that was the
first time he's okay yeah I think it was
a good you get here the first time even
technique that was much better
I practice every day maybe in the doom
who are Samira basketball players now
that you're more into I like to run
gentlemen yeah okay LeBron newest
student play in the passive cosmic is
dead Durban so scary remember didn't
about him
[Music]
I played in the first team in my country
when I was 17 years old so I was very
very young for the other players so from
that time I just like oh this is my
chance I'll never miss it
yeah I have to work harder to educate
myself after what could a man do
recovery dedication yeah yeah that's
amazing and you did it
yeah it's like crazy but it's amazing
grace and Odell actually I showed you
the video he was like you know I just
admire him
like I said mutual respect for him so
ago yeah the people likes him a lot in
England yes the players talking they ask
me even how do you see him did you meet
each other do you know each other before
I say no just maybe oh yeah have you met
LeBron James yet no I'm not yes okay but
one day fund it yeah we're coming he's a
little big love yeah I mean how so
so every show we do and take me segments
and now it is your turn to take me
somewhere already take me to your
favorite goal ever it's different it's
different because it's it's about how
the goal is important for you but for me
I think the gold start to change my life
more is that the World Cup game doctor
we I scored the penalty I scored against
Congo when we qualify to the World Cup
top 28 years so that's something I have
to choose it take me to the best part of
that commercial shoot with I think I can
choose the trick shot you know the one
with the first time that was it was very
nice but all the commercial had fun on
it so so you did that much with Messi
most of the most of the people according
to his player ever that's something very
huge and something like very very
excited for me and for the team also so
that's something great take me to your
morning coffee routine that's something
never change so I wake up in the morning
shower do meditation then get a coffee
then put a clock how many coffees
throughout the day do you have depends
in Italy I used to have more because
we're copying Italy's dinner so we end
every interview with a closing video
selfie and picture selfie so now it's
your turn okay here with masala and all
that hair thank you very much
great the hair today
okay perfect you're great thank you
hello guys it is Taylor rooks thank you
so much for watching my show take it
there but now you have to subscribe you
don't want to miss the next interview
and all the fun stuff we're doing on the
YouTube channel so hit that subscribe
button two things see you guys soon